[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous
alors pourquoi est-ce que je suis là
avec vous ce soir
ben ya une chose qui m'obsède
une chose qui me travaille au corps et à
l'esprit depuis quelques années c'est la
transmission d'histoire comment on fait
pour intéresser les jeunes à l'histoire
bon certes ça fait des années qu'on
enseigne l'histoire ça fait même des
milliers d'années qu'on enseigne soit on
pourrait remonter à hérodote à
l'antiquité je vais pas le faire à
serez-vous mais plutôt comment on fait
pour les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ceux qui
sont prêts dans l'instantanéité
l'ordinaire
la facilité d'accéder à des choses qui
sans arrêt sont changeantes
comment on fait pour leur raconter une
histoire notre histoire l'histoire en
général
bon il ya quand même quelque chose
d'assez intéressant dans l'histoire
c'est le récit le verbe la puissance du
verbe qu'une capacité d'emporter deux
nous illuminer et là dessus je suis sûr
que vous en avez des professeurs
d'histoire et on racontait qu'en été à
la petite école on dit lui il nous
racontait l'histoire et on avait besoin
de rien oui mais les jeunes à l'époque
n'avait rien entendons nous à l'époque
ils ont pas les cellulaires excusez moi
les portables ou parce qu'on est un peu
juste un accent mais aussi des mots
différents mais j'ose croire que ça
enrichit et donc comme ils ont beaucoup
de stimulation ils ne sont plus
intéressés par ce qu'on a à raconter et
c'est pas juste un problème français
c'est un problème occidentale même à
travers le monde
l'histoire ne passe plus comment faire
pour y arriver
mais j'ai quelques constats pour vous
qui se font assez évident je pense qu'on
va s'entendre là-dessus
les jeunes ne connaissent pas leur
histoire ils ne s'y intéressent pas
internet et les réseaux sociaux ont tué
le contenu et la connaissance alors si
vous me permettez d'être un peu hautain
faux faux faux
tout ce que vous avez devant vous ces
défaites nous on pourrait même dire de
la fake instruit ça ne rend pas compte
de l'intérêt qu'ont les jeunes pour
l'histoire et quand vous regardez
la production culturelle comme par
exemple les jeux vidéo mais les jeux
vidéo depuis 2002
c'est le premier médium culturel en
termes d'argent ont fait plus d'argent
avec les jeux vidéo qu'avec les films
d'hollywood
c'est vous dire c'est des milliards de
dollars qui sont investis et l'histoire
est un terrain de jeu c'est un terrain
de jeu pour apprendre
donc quand vous arrivez dans un cours
magistral avec les étudiants et vous
essayez de l'étudiant s'assoit et
pendant trois heures lui raconte des
choses qu'il est sa seule réaction arc
je vais me faire chier et à juste titre
moi le premier si on me raconte des
choses et ample selon d une nouvelle
technique parce que certains profs ont
le grand avantage d'être à la fine
pointe de la technologie est d'arriver
avec des pointes et se disent je vais
balancer des images réduire les lumières
et avoir une voix monocorde le power
point tu deviens un port somnifère
est ce que c'est ça que vous voulez
faire
je ne pense pas c'est sûr que l'histoire
cette grande capacité d'utiliser des
images des films la musique
mais pourquoi pas des jeux vidéo
pourquoi est-ce qu'on délaisse le jeu
vidéo 10 ans et de la culture populaire
c'est là ça fait la ludification la
l'encasernement des esprits c'est la
stupidité au carré
encore une fois faux faux faux faux bond
j'ai travaillé pour ubisoft pour un
petit jeu qui s'appelle assassin's creed
une et y avait peut-être été mis au
courant parce qu un petit débat est
d'ailleurs les médias français ont été
mis au courant du jeu cause d'un homme
politique
on va l'écouter le jeu vidéo c'est une
forme d'art et celui ci celui ci vous
dérange pourquoi parce que chez c'est de
la propagande donc je réagis comme ça
chez la propagande contre le peuple
preuves solides et barbares des sauvages
alors jean luc mélenchon quand même a eu
l'idée de lancer le débat après il
arrêtait de parler parce qu'il s'est
rendu compte que fallait il laisser les
historiens travail est une chance mais
qu'est ce que c'est une chouette unity
je pourrais vous en parler pendant des
heures je pourrais vous parler de
l'intérêt qu'on a pour reconstituer
paris mais je ne pensais je voulais ses
listes
[Musique]
quand même impressionnant vous le dire
mais quel est l'avantagé du jeu vidéo
par rapport au film le film se trame
narrative on peut pas en sortir le jeu
vidéo n'en déplaise à jean luc on peut
entrer dans une structure immersif
on peut véritablement revivre ce que les
gens ont vécu mais là qu'est ce que j'ai
fait comme travail mois avec ubisoft
ils m'ont demandé grossièrement de
reconstituer pari de faire des
élévations de plans à quoi ça ressemble
à l'intérieur des habitations des
maisons les litois à quoi ressemblaient
les planches et dans les armoires
qu'est-ce qui avait comme but mais
qu'est-ce qui avait comme pau est ce
qu'ils avaient des toilettes à l'époque
donc j'en avais pas les trottoirs est ce
qu'ils étaient de l'infiniment petit
mais plus encore travailler avec la vie
quotidienne vous savez ces grands
événements qui font l'histoire comme la
prise de la bastille
moi ce qui m'intéresse aussi c'est les
éléments de faible intensité les rumeurs
l'opinion publique
l'hygiène la politesse la police tout ce
qui fonde un ordinaire et qui permet de
réduire la distance entre vous et eux et
que eux et nous ne formons plus qu'un
seul de parler des choses très
quotidienne
certes le verbe permet de nous amener à
n'importe où mais quand on la soie avec
l'image canton la soie avec ce contexte
qui nous donne le xviiie siècle le
xviiie siècle est présent l'histoire
devient présente et c'est la fonction de
la vulgarisation plutôt de la
transmission
j'aime pas le terme vulgarisation on se
rattache ou vulgaire on pense que
l'universitaire que je suis et comme mes
collègues doivent descendre de leur tour
d'ivoire pour donner ou vulgaire non
c'est pas ça
j'ai une fonction sociale je suis payé
par l'état pour travailler et donner à
mes semble si je ne fais pas je manque à
ma fonction
donc qu'est-ce que je peux faire avec
les jeux vidéo peut-être vous connaissez
cette application qui s'attaquent google
street view
donc c'est assez connu si vous la
connaissez pas vous avez été cryogénisé
devant les vingt dernières années comme
en solo
mais imaginez imaginez un écran dit m
comme on a devant vous la sono nouba
sono un curseur comme celui là ici avec
le curseur on entre dans paris
non dans paris mais pas un pari statique
mais paris 1789 la foule bouge
les mendiants la police bon ne pas
encore l'odeur quoi pour me dit que ça
pouvait arriver ça mais tout ça tout
arrive dans paris et vous vivez la chose
et claque avec un clic sur le pointeur
ya un vol qui se produit la police
déboule
on suit le truc vous êtes vraiment dans
la ville et les étudiants qui voient ça
on se dit ah oui le jeu auquel je joue
ou qu'elle mes parents pensent que je
suis en train de devenir chrétien en y
jouant trop peut être utile et pour le
prouver avec mon collègue de
l'université paris sorbonne jean clément
martin qui était l'autre consultant sur
assassin's creed une éthique on ne
produit un livre un livre dans lequel on
raconte la trame narrative c'était ce
que faisait jean clément martin et de ma
partie à moi c'était sur la physionomie
à vie ordinaire de la ville
ce qui fait que les enseignants qui
veulent utiliser assassin's creed unity
dans les classes peuvent le faire j'ai
donné ce qu'on appelle en anglais un
work choo des promenades que l'on peut
faire ou l'enseignant peut utiliser et
ça se fait chez nous au québec mais bien
entendu avec mon accent mémo spéciaux
nous nous étudions la révolution
française par les jeux vidéo nous nous
sommes adaptés
on est dans le conte et unième siècle
pendant train de critiquer la france
quoique
et à quoi ça ressemblerait si on pouvait
entrer dans la ville ne parlait de notre
dame
notre dame et brûlé on la reverra pas
son nom certains certains pensent que ça
va être cinq ans d'autres plus mais les
graver dans le numérique
elle est gravée dans le jeu et on peut
dès aujourd'hui l'utiliser dans nos
cours pour montrer aux étudiants
voilà ce à quoi ressemblait la
cathédrale pas celle du xiiie siècle
parce que celle qui reproduisent dans le
jeu comme on avait les plans viollet le
duc dans leur remise dans le jeu à
partir des plantes viollet le duc
donc on a une conceptualisations qui est
déjà présente
on dit souvent que si vous voulez
connaître les choses y a qu'à se baisser
ou plutôt à s'asseoir sur son ordinateur
et à apprendre
la révolution technologique n'est plus
une révolution des paons depuis
longtemps doit transformer l'éducation
doit transformer la manière d'enseigner
au verbe que che en train de vous de
faire en ce moment on doit adjoindre
l'image d'une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle l'histoire nous dira j'ai fais
des romans historiques série qui se
passe à québec au xviiie siècle dans le
froid
parfait pour vous les français qui
pensait qu'on vit en terre et pendant
six mois ce qu'il faut et là je me dis
qu'elle est la suite parce que mon grand
plaisir et mon devoir que je me suis
donné c'est de tester toutes les
méthodes existent pour transmettre
l'histoire de la vulgariser comme j'ai
dit à l'ats par amp vulgaire facile
accessible en disant tout simplement
suivez moi non simplement vous la
raconter en réduisant la distance et
peut-être que ce qu'il faut que je fasse
ce faire des one man show mais pas juste
un one man show est ce que je suis là
tout cela vous raconter avec des
projections à gauche à droite
utilisez-les architecture immersive les
jeux vidéo qui est déjà présente parce
qu'elles sont inscrits c'est pô juste
paris 1789 c'est la renaissance des
médicis c'est les pirates des caraîbes
c'est la révolution américaine de 1776
c'est londres au 19e siècle et c'est la
grèce antique
vous avez un vaste panorama de
l'histoire
l'histoire est un terrain de jeu et
pourquoi pas jeux vidéo merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]